[Music]
then we'll Massachusetts pick that we do
is to bring in a distinguished
individual and once per year applause
about activities within various aspects
of the sea from the from the folder
we've had a very long distinguished
group of the previous eleven speakers in
this series on speaker this afternoon
didn't have to travel very far the
president's blood countess Baron says
his office across the hall from this
from this meeting room where he is the
director of the Center for Space
Research Claude received all of his
education up the river at Harvard has
been a leader here at MIT in the
development of the earlier known as the
Chandra will be the subject of his
lecture today is been notable for his
government service and public service in
helping all of us in having our face
space objectives realize and among the
many things that he has done he's
chaired the Space Studies board of the
National Research Council it's my great
blood with privilege to introduce pod
catasaurus to speak about probing the
violet universe with the Chandra x-ray
Observatory thank you very much Larry I
guess I have to go on the air now how
does that work you get some you get some
amplification back there
no did the did they get turned on maybe
the amplifier isn't turned on well while
we're working on that I'm more
instrumented almost than the satellite
you see in front of you but to the
satellites actually working well
no no right now we have spectrum the
wrong switch
how's that excellent well it's a great
pleasure to be here and to have traveled
so far for this occasion the it's also
great because I always enjoy talking
about this I have been having an
extraordinary amount of fund in the
recent than in the past year and a half
since Chandra was launched and one of
the things which I will regretfully will
not be able to do sufficiently is to
mention the names of many of the people
in this room and of great many more who
are not in this room who contributed to
the things I'm about to describe and
made all this possible one of the things
that is a less described pleasure of
working in an area like space science
and space research is the chance to work
closely with with a great number of very
dedicated and talented engineers
scientists managers people who have
bring together a lot of different skills
in order to make a project like this
happen and so I want to start with a
tribute to them even though I won't have
a chance to mention them all in as we go
along well the what just disappeared
from the screen is the picture of
Chandra this is a large satellite that
was launched by NASA just a year and a
half ago in July of 99 and its purpose
is to join with the Hubble Space
Telescope the Compton gamma-ray
Observatory and and shortly this is the
space infrared telescope facility in
probing the universe with the greatest
possible precision this Observatory in
contrast to the others that I mentioned
in the Hubble which is probably well
known to most of you has been in the
news a great deal studies x-rays and in
studying x-rays we study the hottest and
most violent objects in the universe and
so what I'm going to do today is to tell
you a little bit about the satellite
and some significant fraction of the
scientific instrumentation was built in
fact in this building and at MIT and
then up another part up the street at
the Smithsonian Astrophysical
Observatory and then to give you a
little bit of a glimpse of the kinds of
things that we've been learning with
this remarkable new tool first of all a
word about x-ray since I know that many
of you are very familiar but some of you
may be not so familiar with with the
fundamental properties x-rays are of
course another kind of electromagnetic
radiation but with wavelengths about a
thousand times shorter and therefore
energies per photon or per quantum a
thousand times higher than that of
visible light and so having more
energetic quanta more energetic photons
means that in order to produce these
x-rays you have to go you have to have
some some object that's somehow either
very hot or very energetic so if you
take the spectrum of radiation of which
the visible light of course is only a
very small piece in the middle the
x-rays have wavelength of about in the
our case say 10 angstroms or one
nanometer and correspond to a
temperature of millions to hundreds of
millions of degrees and so that's the
kinds of objects that we study and of
course in order to learn about the
universe which is a vast place in which
gives up its secrets only grudgingly the
goal in astronomy and astrophysics for
the last forty years has been to expand
our grasp of this electromagnetic
spectrum as much as possible and an
important part of that is this x-ray
band that I will be talking about today
now I can give you a very close to home
example of the difference between
studying things with x-rays and visible
light this is our familiar Sun the
photosphere of the Sun these days it's
more active and has more spots on it but
otherwise it's a fairly bland surface
and
the visible light that we see is
generated by gas at the temperature of
the surface of the Sun which is the
temperature of maybe five thousand
degrees the typical temperature of the
reasonable flame and that's you know in
a candle or a Bunsen burner and that's
why it looks the same color if you take
the exact same object and look at it
with an x-ray telescope as was done
first about twenty years ago and then
more recently with it with a number of
satellite instruments you see a very
different picture this is the same Sun
and those two pictures were not taken
exactly the same time but they could
have been and yet here what we see now
is material not at the temperature of a
candle flame of thousands of degrees but
at a temperature of millions to ten
million degrees and this is very hot gas
confined in magnetic loops in the so
called solar corona that extends way
above the surface of the Sun and so when
we look at the Sun in x-rays we see a
very different set of phenomena if we
want to understand this very energetic
phenomena then we have to look with
telescopes like like Chandra now why did
I say that this picture and Chandra
itself is a satellite you know and why
do we go to the difficulty since the
visible light picture was taken from the
earth of putting our instruments in
space and of course the reason is that
the Earth's atmospheric mantle is
extraordinarily opaque to x-rays which
is probably a good thing for us but as
human beings but not such a good thing
for us as x-ray astronomers so so the
only way we can we can study these
x-rays is to send our instruments above
the atmosphere and this was done first
in about 1963 and a project led by the
then MIT professor bruno rossi who is in
many many consider the father or maybe
the grandfather of x-ray astronomy so we
go up into space and that's what we
that's what we do in order
to measure these x-rays and the by far
most precise and and largest instrument
that's been devised to do this is the
Chandra Observatory now the Chandra
Observatory is an x-ray telescope so it
has a something which acts like a lens
which focuses x-rays which are shown
here as little orange dots focuses
x-rays from very distant source onto a
sensitive detector at the other end and
which will then record the image the key
thing is that is this this telescope
which actually does the focusing now
focusing x-rays is an extraordinarily
difficult thing to do and that's one of
the reasons why this mission was so long
in the making x-rays are very
penetrating and if you shine them
straight into a mirror they would simply
absorb and the only way to get x-rays to
bend sufficiently to focus to a point
for example if they come from a point
source in the distance is to coax them
very gradually to to change their
direction by having them skip off a very
highly polished surface much as Rock
will see you can skip off the surface of
a pond although if you threw it straight
into the pond it would just go clump in
through this through the surface and so
Chandra has four sets of these highly
polished so in nearly cylindrical
surface is a very slight curvature to do
the bending and and very highly polished
in order to accomplish the focusing and
these mirrors were made over a period of
many years at an outfit which is now
Raytheon but at the time was Hughes
danbury optical systems and before that
was PerkinElmer and in which guys they
made the Hubble mirror so we had a lot
of confidence that this would be done
right
and you can see here this polishing this
is this was a this was really the heart
of getting Chandra to have it its
properties which I'll mention in a
moment and just to give you an idea in
order to to make these mirrors because
you can see you're coming in at such a
shallow angle you have to polish a great
deal of glass in order to get a
relatively small frontal projected area
a collecting area to collect the the
x-rays in fact the the effective frontal
area of this telescope is about a
thousand square centimeters and yet we
had to polish something like twenty
square meters in order to to get those
thousand square meters projected
effective area the surface quality is is
extraordinary the the the average
roughness of the surface is three
angstroms which is which which I like to
always make an analogy that if you were
to polish the surface of the earth to
that precision then the the equivalent
bumpiness of the surface of the earth if
we scaled these mirrors of properties to
the Earth's surface would be a few
millimeters so it's an extraordinarily
well done job and they did it well and
it focused when we got it onto orbit
the mirrors are then coated with iridium
a heavy metal in order to increase the
efficiency for bending these x-rays at a
glancing angle and when we're all done
the telescope was assembled this was
actually done by Eastman Kodak in under
everything is done under very clean
conditions in the space business it's
known that terrorists make excellent
workers and you can see they're already
dressed for the job and a precision
alignment and when we're all done the
the image quality that's was achieved
with these mirrors is something like a
half an arc second which is a factor ten
better than had ever been but Eve dwith
us with an x-ray telescope in the past
well the the mirror of course is just
what happens
what focuses the X rays then there is a
long tube the whole focal length of
these mirrors is about 10 meters so it's
an extraordinarily large satellite and
the telescope in this picture would go
in the front fits in here along with the
spacecraft and then in the back are the
instruments that detect the X rays and
I'll show you those in a moment here's
the spacecraft portion TRW was the prime
contractor and this was the the final
assembly was in Redondo Beach California
and their plant there and this is the
you know the thing that has the
transmitters in the power system and so
forth the telescope fits in the middle
of this and this is and then the solar
panels stick out either side lets you
make the picture that I showed you in
the opening slide the whoops
it's at the focal at the focus then we
have several instruments that can record
the images this one I'm showing you here
was built was one of the ones built here
at MIT in collaboration with MIT Lincoln
lab it's a CCD detector for those of you
who know what that means the
charge-coupled devices optimized for use
in the x-ray band and they're 2 or 2
rows of them I won't dwell on that but
these are these have been developed in a
something like a 20 year effort the
collaboration between George Ricker and
mark bouts and the people at Lincoln lab
who have optimized these for use with
the x-rays and they are an extremely
good detector I'll say more about them
as we go along and then the other
instrument that was built here in this
largely in this building is one of these
two funny arrays this one actually is
the one that came from a German Dutch
collaboration the one built here at MIT
is slightly out of view here these are
periodic nano structures which can be
placed
behind the telescope these these are
sort of hinged structures the telescope
in this picture is sitting looking down
on the floor below can be put behind the
telescope and to spread the x-rays out
in a spectrum and I'll show you an
example of how that works and that's the
collaboration which I had with mark
Shannon Berg and Hank Smith over in
electrical engineering and computer
science and to adapt the techniques of
large-scale integrated circuit
fabrication to the needs for our project
well finally all these pieces came
together it was a it says why I took 15
years to deploy the x-ray telescope I
didn't tell you that I was selected as a
principal investigator on Chandra in
1984 I daresay there's some people in
this room that were barely alive at that
stage and it was for a long time I
called it Orwell's curse because at that
point we were supposed to launch Chandra
in in 1991 and then the launch slipped a
year per year for the next eight years
and and then finally it stopped slipping
we did a lot of political work and and
redesign work along the way and in fact
developed even better instruments but
finally all those pieces all those
players that I mentioned under the
direction of Marshall Space Flight
Center which was the the center that
directed this effort came together and
we were ready to go here is the Chandra
was loaded into the shuttle bay shuttle
was the launch vehicle after a lot of
discussion it turned out that that was
the launch vehicle of choice and the
size of the the telescope here wrapped
in its insulating reflecting material
together with a an extra rocket stage
because the shuttle leaves this in a
very low orbit and we wanted to end up
in a very high orbit just fills the
shuttle bay I mean that's not by
accident that was by desired and luckily
there were no metric to English
conversions that
got in the way of that activity
this was the shuttle launch in July of
99 first one commanded by a woman
commander Eileen Collins and included
Cady Coleman who is an MIT alumna and
also an alumna of the University of
Massachusetts so that's if the space
grant had been around at that time she
probably would have been supported by
the space grant and she's the one who
actually pushed the button to get
Chandra out of the shuttle bay and so
the the astronauts were ready in fact
they were ready three times they loaded
themselves in and then there were two
scrubs and then finally on July 23rd of
99 the shuttle took off just after
midnight it was an extraordinarily
impressive sight if any of you have not
seen a shuttle launch particularly a
night launch and are in Florida at the
time I urge you to do it it's really
extraordinary it took off our little
periodic nanostructures we're in there
being shaken to pieces but not to pieces
that turned out luckily and then very
shortly afterwards when shuttle got on
orbit they as they deployed they started
the sequence to deploy Chandra first it
it's on a hinged system in the back so
that this thing which used to be lying
in the shuttle bay is now already
elevated to the position at which it
will be gently pushed off by just by
mechanical Springs that were released
Cady Coleman issued the command and and
Chandra was off here you can see the
telescope and here the the inertial so
called inertial upper stage which is the
the rocket that was to take it to a
final orbit shuttle backed away a
discreet distance and that rocket was
fired then a series of burnings and it
got it up to its final orbit which is a
64 our orbit with a an Apogee of about
140,000 kilometers and a perigee of
around 12 or 14,000 kilometers
here's the crew very happy that they got
this bomb out of the shuttle bay I think
and they got their work done very early
in the mission you can see that in those
in zero-g every day's a bear
bad hair day but but they were indeed
very happy and I have to say it was it
was a great pleasure working with these
astronauts who were very dedicated to
this task of getting Chandra we're very
excited about the scientific
implications of the job that they were
doing in space and came and visited us a
number of times beforehand learned about
the mission came afterwards to see how
how it was doing and and that was that
was a privilege of the privilege of
working in these space programs is to
work with people like this
well the operations as soon as the
shuttle bay doors were open Chandra was
controlled from the control center which
is just up the street it's in a rented
space and Draper lab this is the
operations control center it's the only
control center that can run Chandra but
it's the first time nASA has allowed a
major observatory of this class to be
operated entirely by an outside entity
not under their direct control and the
Smithsonian Astrophysical Observatory is
the parent organization MIT is also
involved in the Chandra Science Center
that helps run this activity and and the
operations have been extraordinarily
smooth that's it's really again and one
of the remarkable things is how how well
this has worked although I was just
informed earlier today that because of
another major solar flare the satellite
is once again gone into a safe mode
which it tends to do to protect itself
when that happens but other than that
which are more acts of God than then
man-made the OP this the operation has
been very very good so so that brings us
then to what we've been doing for the
last year and a half well the first
several months of course we're checking
out all the instruments calibrating
everything during all the usual things
one does learning a little bit how to
operate it
most efficiently the operation now is
extra is extremely efficient most of the
actual available time for doing science
is spent doing science not doing other
things which isn't always the case with
missions that this complex so so now I'm
going to shift gears and stop telling
you about the thing itself and rather
the kinds of things that we were that
we're learning and this will be just a
sort of a light overview of the kinds of
objects that we study the way we use
this tool to probe the cosmic violence I
talked about in my in the title so I'll
start actually with something which
doesn't appear so violent but is
actually but is a place where instead of
stars dying which I'll talk about in a
moment stars are born and this is a
actually a Hubble picture and
occasionally along the way I will show
optical pictures as well as the x-ray
pictures to help orient you this is a
well known stellar nursery in the
constellation Orion near the dagger of
Orion the which is about 2,000
light-years away and contains a lot of
dust and gas and and new stars that are
forming bright new stars that are
forming many of which are in this
picture are embedded and can't be seen
behind the dust and guess that have
condensed out of this dust and gas and
that are forming even as as we speak and
some of them have formed just within the
last million years or so which in the
lifetime of a star is a very short time
indeed
our Sun is about 5 billion years old so
that gives you a scale the the power of
Chandra I think for me is best indicated
by a picture like this one this is a
picture now not in visible light but in
x-rays taken with Chandra of the central
part of this Orion star forming region
and it shows this sort of dark X pattern
that you see is just the boundary
between
the four CCD chips and you saw that in
the picture of the detector that I
showed you earlier but you can see you
know a whole collection of objects there
about a thousand stars that are seen
here in shining in x-rays the ones in
the middle are there so congested in
this in this picture that they seem to
all form a single blob in fact that's
just the limitations of the reproduction
that I'm showing you if you look at it
more carefully as we have in a actually
a different picture which takes care of
the over exposure you can see many many
very bright objects in the middle those
are indeed very massive stars many of
these are relatively low mass stars that
we think like our Sun probably in its
early in the early years of its life
were unusually active in putting out
x-rays of the kind that I showed you in
the Sun now but but we're a much larger
part of the of the energy output in
those early days there are also objects
here which we think are just starting to
for haven't even turned into fully
formed stars yet that are also for
reasons that are not well understood
starting putting a remarkable amount of
their energy into x-ray production and
so this is an area that's is a very
active study of how this via this this
so-called violence that happens in
heating the material to very high
temperatures in the corona coexists with
the other formation processes that are
going on in in the source and now
well I think they really like this
picture whoops oh now we we had we went
to sleep for a moment let's we'll get
back to there we are all right so much
for stellar birth let's go to stellar
death that's always more fun a lot of
the things that we study have to do with
the products of of what happens not at
the beginning of a star's life but at
its end
this shows a visible light picture of a
piece of the sky in the constellation
Cassiopeia which has been known for many
years to be the remnant of a supernova
explosion a star that ended its life in
a cataclysmic explosion which we think
is not at all uncommon way for stars to
die and which was probably seen by the
astronomer Flamsteed about 350 years ago
and recorded visibly as a bright object
in the sky the thing that's interesting
from the point of view of astrophysics
is this this little debris here is the
remnant of the explosion all the other
dots are just normal stars and this is a
visible light picture again remember and
so this is just a little wispy stuff
which is a small amount of debris which
came out of the inside of the star now
one of the things there are a number of
reasons why these explosions are of
interest but one of the things that
interested me a lot and some of my
colleagues is the fact that these are
the sources these supernovae are the
sources of all the chemical elements
that are of interest to us other than
hydrogen and helium in the early
universe there was virtually nothing but
hydrogen and helium and all of the
carbon nitrogen oxygen silicon sulfur
etc etcetera
had to come out of the interior of the
nucleo synthetic furnaces inside a star
and then be ejected so that it could mix
with other material to form things like
planet Earth otherwise those
and simply wouldn't be there so one of
the things we like to study is this is
the is the material as it comes out of
the supernova explosion because that's a
unique opportunity to see stuff just as
the Stars turn come you know obligingly
turned itself inside out to us to allow
you to look inside and see the material
there before it disperses so so broadly
in in the in the galaxy that it's no
longer visible I should say that this
object is about 5,000 or 6,000 light
years away and it's about 10 light years
across that gives you a scale this is
this this ring now it turns out these
things are our ops absolutely ideal
objects for study in the x-ray here's
the Chandra image of exactly that same
ring that same piece of the sky and now
instead of seeing a few wisps they still
looks wispy but I can tell you that by
adding up all the material here we can
see the bulk of this material that came
out of the star in the center when it
exploded is seen in this picture now
heated up to temperatures of about 10
million degrees by the shock that it
encounters as it flies out from the
initial explosion and the initial
explosion sends out the material at
velocities of about 5,000 kilometers per
second so it's it's moving and when it
runs into stuff around it it gets very
it gets heated to these very high
temperatures now one of the things that
that is of great interest as I just said
was to study the chemical composition of
this and the cameras that were built for
Chandra give us really the opportunity
to do that the x-rays that come out are
have energies which are very
characteristic of the element that's
emitting the x-ray so that you can
actually do a chemical analysis by
looking at these the wavelength the
precise wavelength of the x-ray or as
it's depicted in this picture of the
color and I should say that the previous
slide the color was just used to
indicate the intensity here is one case
where the colour is indicated is used to
actually indicate the energy of the
x-ray and I can tell you for example
that these red
blobs over here are almost pure iron
that was ejected from the interior of
the suit of the supernovae and that are
flying out and then there's there are
others that are that are that are
heavily and enriched with silicon and
software so we're actually seeing the
elements that are that were synthesized
in the interior of the star and are now
being ejected and one can do an analysis
of those and these are I should say that
this was this was a very massive star
was probably about 20 times the mass of
the Sun before it exploded so there's a
lot of material there and I'll be
talking about say another word about
those kinds of stars in the next picture
whoops did I skip over no I guess I
didn't this is another case of of such a
supernova remnant here it is this ring
now this one actually looks smaller in
this picture and it appears smaller on
the sky but it's actually larger in in
linear dimensions because it's much
further away this is a but it's
similarly the ring that's left over this
is again another Chandra picture I'll
tell you about this rainbow in a moment
just look at this part for a second this
is again a picture of this stellar
debris that it's flying out from from a
an explosion thought now to be about a
thousand years in the past instead of
350 as I showed you before but again is
the supernova from a very massive story
this is just much farther away this is
about 150,000 light-years away in
actually a very small neighbor galaxy of
ours called the Small Magellanic Cloud
now I mentioned the other instrument
that was that was built here at MIT is
this these little devices that when put
in the beam spread the the the x-rays
out in all their colors and in this
display where where we've also used the
color of the display to emphasize that
point you can see little images of the
supernova remnant but you know displaced
and exactly where they fall depends on
the wavelength of the x-ray that's
that's doing the
that's that's dominating the emission
and you can see from the labels up above
that each one of those rings corresponds
to a different element so with this
instrument we can go along and actually
measure independently the location in
this supernova remnant of neon or
magnesium or oxygen and and really do
not just a chemical analysis but a
detailed spatial analysis of the
material and that for example gives us a
picture of only in this case only oxygen
where oxygen was emitted in this
explosion and I said this was a fairly
massive star this may have even even
been more massive than the previous one
but say 20 sir so solar masses of star
it managed to turn itself into probably
you know somewhere between 3 & 5 solar
masses of oxygen alone and it is these
stars which are relatively rare in the
galaxy but which when they explode
provide the bulk of the oxygen that
enriches the universe and so they're
particularly of interest to those of us
who think oxygen is a useful thing and
so when you take your next breath you'll
be breathing actually there piece of a
supernova remnant luckily it's cooled
down but by now but and and to give you
a scale our solar system has only a tiny
fraction of a solar mass worth of oxygen
there's enough oxygen coming out in this
explosion to seed and once it's finally
mixed with other elements some many
thousands worth of solar systems with
with the same amount of oxygen that we
have in ours so they're they're real
stellar warehouses if you like of oxygen
one of the other things that we can do
with this very fine
spectral information is to actually look
for for velocity information as well
using the well-known Doppler shift which
shifts very slightly the wavelengths of
the lines and so this picture shows that
remnant and there were arrows on top of
it are to indicate the velocities that
we can measure around this ring the red
ones in
our indicate velocities away from us
so-called redshift and these would be
blue shifts or velocities towards us and
the scale is such that this arrow
corresponds to a velocity of about 2,000
kilometers per second so now we can we
not only see the elements that are
coming out but we can actually measure
the the velocity of ejection from the
original explosion and and measure its
energy the total amount of energy that's
released by the way in one of these
supernova explosions is is very
considerable it's ten to the fifty-one
herbs for those of you who are working
CGS units of the way we do which is
comparable to the amount of energy that
the Sun puts out on a daily basis but if
you add up that total over almost the
full lifetime of the Sun so it's a it's
a very large amount of energy that gets
put out and that's what we're trying to
measure now those of you who saw this
picture earlier probably noticed
something which I neglected to mention
that little dot in the middle and one of
the other interesting aspects in fact
this was actually our so-called first
light picture this is the first
astronomical object that we pointed
chandra at and as soon as it came up on
the screen all the astronomers in the
room you know focused on this thing
because this hadn't been seen before
it's a very because the previous images
simply didn't you know we're too blurry
they were blurrier than this and this
just looked like another blurry thing
like that little blurry blob or that
blurry blob but when you have very sharp
focus it turns out that that's
effectively a point for years people
have been wondering about what happens
in this in this particular case what
happened to the very central part of the
star that exploded to give rise to this
debris it's been known again for many
years that in that these supernova
explosions are not only the origin of
the chemical elements in the universe
but also the origin of very collapsed
central objects the central core of the
star which collapses gravitationally and
is what actually drives the the
explosion of the outer part
and Wichern which are either neutron
stars or the ultimate collapsed object
black holes and this it was a puzzle why
this this object didn't have one and the
answer is simply it does have one but it
wasn't clearly seen before so one of the
interesting objects of study in x-ray
astronomy is now not now I'm switching
from the study of the debris to the
question about the nature and properties
of these highly collapsed objects
neutron stars or black holes neutron
stars are stars with a mass comparable
to that of the Sun but but the
dimensions of the city limits in Boston
and so it's extraordinarily dense they
have densities of the nucleus of an atom
which I actually sat on my calculator to
convert is about a hundred million tons
per cubic centimeter and because of
their great density they often have very
energetic phenomena associated with them
either because material is falling into
them because they're spinning rapidly
they're just their great mass density
often translates into a great other
energetic phenomena and so they are very
interesting objects for the study of
x-rays and got so many instruments here
I can't keep track of them sometimes
these collapsed objects either neutron
stars or black holes are formed in a
supernova explosion in which the star
that that gave rise to that has a
companion and the companion could be a
normal relatively normal star by the way
I said that Chandra has very good
angular resolution but it wasn't good
enough to take this picture this is an
artist's conception this is a normal
star and it also doesn't show the x-rays
is these funny little Wiggly lines but
in which the companion is one of these
very collapsed stars it's so collapsed
that as material is pulled off the this
this companion star and falls down and
down and down and down seemingly forever
until it hits or disappears into the
black hole at the center there's an
enormous amount of energy released more
than you would get from nuclear fusion
for example if you just if all that's
you could just fuse all that stuff in a
in a reactor so so there's a great deal
of energy emitted and that energy comes
out primarily as x-rays and so these are
objects of which there's a lot of
interest in which we can learn a lot of
both about the objects and about how
they interact with their companions by
looking in Chandra here is just a
picture of one of these in our galaxy
and you can see the some of the streaks
here from from the spectrum that I
because this picture was taken with the
spectrometers in place but and there's a
lot to be learned but more than I can
tell you in the short time so instead
I'm going to move to a larger scale
where you'll see these same kinds of
objects but now in larger in greater
numbers a friend from a greater distance
this is an entire galaxy of stars and
this one is a particularly active galaxy
it's a galaxy that's that's now outside
of our Milky Way which of course is our
own galaxy at a distance of about 10
million light-years and it this is a
visible light picture so you see in a
lot of stars these bright stars are in
our galaxy we're looking through of
course the stars and our galaxy to see
the more distant one and this looks a
little funny it's disturbed it's also
well the their limitations of the
PowerPoint resolution as well here too
but you can see these dust lanes this is
an area in which there's a great deal of
stellar birth and stellar death going on
simultaneously is a burst of activity
when you look at it with with Chandra
you see a sort of an ensemble of things
that are the same kinds of things I've
just been describing but now seeing all
all together there's a lot of diffuse
gas this stuff blown out here and this
is because there's so much stellar birth
and stellar death going on
that there are that many many supernovae
went off more or less all at the same
time and have blown out the whole inner
part of the gas in this galaxy and then
you see these very bright objects which
are in fact x-ray binaries of the kind I
just described in which there is a
collapsed remnant of a supernova that is
accreting material and glowing very
brightly in x-rays and this is the our
neighbor galaxy Andromeda which is which
which is a little bit closer it's a
couple of million light-years away and
this is again a visible light image and
you see all the stars a galaxy like this
and like our Milky Way has maybe
something like a hundred billion stars
in it and the very center was imaged by
Chandra this little dark box here
indicates the part in the picture I'm
about to show you and there again we see
these these evidence for both some
diffuse gas but also these very bright
x-ray binaries of the kind that I've
been describing but the center of this
galaxy and in fact we believe the
Centers of every galaxy has another kind
of object as well as shown here as a as
a blue dot because it has a slightly has
a different x-ray color and these
objects we think are in contrast to the
sort of stellar sized objects I've been
talking about so far are very massive
black holes which are formed from from
the accumulation of debris from all the
stars over the over the lifetime of the
galaxies collecting down in the very
center of the galaxy the lowest point if
you like in the gravitational potential
where this degree debris collects and
eventually collapsed to form a very
massive black hole in this case in the
case of our neighbor Andromeda something
may be around a hundred million times
the mass of the Sun but in in other
cases up to a billion or an even ten
billion times the mass of the Sun now
these objects themselves are really
fascinating their own right they are the
largest black holes that we know about
as I say up to ten million I'm sorry ten
billions solar masses and they caused a
remarkable amount of disruption in their
neighborhoods their the the force of
gravity is so strong here that material
as it falls in again releases a great
deal of energy processes as we don't
entirely understand which I'll show you
in a moment conspire that as the stuff
spirals in some of it is actually
squirted out again in extremely
energetic Jets where the material is
traveling very very close to the speed
of light
and so these objects are maybe in terms
of single objects among the densest most
energetic in the universe and of course
therefore our prime objects for study
with Chandra here's our own the center
of our own galaxy by the way and this
work is also being done here at MIT this
is an image of the center of our galaxy
and it looks kind of like that that
stellar birth death case I've been
described was describing before this is
a region that's maybe several tens of
light-years across in the center of our
galaxy there's a there's a fair amount
of activity going on not nearly as much
as in the active galaxy I showed you
before but all these dots are probably
x-ray binaries and the general diffuse
gas that you see here is mainly left
over from supernova explosions and
there's one dot there which is this the
massive black hole that's in the center
of our own galaxy which is actually
remarkably quiet as an x-ray source
compared to some of the others that that
that we know but is is a very
interesting one because you know it's
our own and we feel certain ownership of
it right here's here's a case where we
can actually see some of this energetic
activity this is another district kind
of disturbed galaxy this is a galaxy
which again has been known for some time
to have a lot of activity associated
with it the dust Lane this is visible
light picture again the dust Lane in
case that probably there was maybe a
smaller galaxy was swallowed up fell
into the large one and and was stripped
of its dust and that may have triggered
some of the activity the this galaxy is
about ten million light years away and
this picture is probably about the you
know from here to here might be tens of
thousands of light years or so now when
we look at it with with Chandra at this
same picture and it's roughly the same
the same scale this is why we see well
you can see the scale because actually
this is a superposition this is the
optical picture seen in in sort of
bluish white light with a dust lane and
the red is the Chandra picture and you
can see sort of shining through without
any doubt is this is a very strong x-ray
source right in the center that is the
massive black hole that sits at the
center of this of this galaxy and you
can see this this long squirt of
material coming out this is one of those
ejections as Jets as they're called of
very energetic particles and the fact
that they glow in x-rays even tens of
thousands of light years away from the
center and that it's so well collimated
in a squirt is is one of the things that
that we're trying to understand what are
the energetic processes that actually
transport this large amount of energy so
efficiently out such large distances
from the central object and then what
can we learn of course about the central
black hole in the middle now when these
things are farther away these are in
more locally this is actually I say is
very energetic but this is relatively
puny to the most energetic of these
objects which are called quasars which
is cases where this same activity is
going on presumably in the center of a
galaxy but now at much greater distances
and much larger energies but before I
get to the quasars I'm going to talk
about one yet another kind of phenomenon
where we where Chandra has helped us
understand what's going on this is an
optical picture actually from Hubble of
a cluster
of galaxies so far I've been talking
about individual galaxies with their
there are a hundred billion stars now
I'm talking about whole clusters of
thousands of such galaxies and this is
this is an example of one these are
found scattered throughout the universe
they are the largest gravitationally
bound objects in the universe in which
thousands of these galaxies are close
enough to swarm around and form a
gravitationally gravitationally bound
system typical dimensions go up to
millions of light years a few million
light years in this case probably the
central this is only the very central
portion maybe only a few hundred
thousand light years across now what we
see here are all the visible stars and
the in the individual galaxies the the
hard dots by they're a few foreground
stars that always creep into a picture
like this but most of the anything
that's fuzzy is a distant galaxy that's
part of this cluster when we look at
such a cluster of galaxies or the x-rays
we see a very different picture again
now instead of the individual galaxies
for the most part what we see is a glow
of a very diffuse region of hot gas that
spread throughout the space in between
these galaxies and which actually
contains more matter than all the stars
in all the galaxies and in the first
place now one of the things that I'll
give you just one example of one of the
things we're learning this is a poor
picture of another cluster of galaxies I
showed the last is the one because it's
much more dramatic but you can see a
couple of galaxies here and then a lot
of other fuzzy dots so this is a poor
reproduction but the reason that this is
interesting one of the things that we
were just now revealing with Chandra is
that these things although they're
gravitationally bound are still in the
process of forming and in this case for
example I'm about to show you the
Chandra picture these are actually two
smaller clusters that have just collided
and started passing through each other
and we can see that in the next picture
where you and then I'll show you what it
reveals that here's this is the
basically the same piece of the sky but
now seen with with an x-ray telescope
you see a diffuse glow from this very
this is this very thin hot gas that
spreads between all the galaxies in the
cluster and these rather sharp edges we
can actually measure the temperature and
the pressure jump across the the edges
these rather sharp edges are indicative
of the fact that they're them this
elongation is indicative of the fact
that they're really two blobs of gas
that have just finished merging and are
one cooler than the other passing
through each other so the dynamics of
how these galaxy clusters formed is
suddenly revealing itself in the by by
means of these x-ray pictures now the
last thing I'll talk about is pushing to
the edge of the universe which is always
you know a good thing to do if you
particularly you want to get headlines
and and it's also a good thing to do
because it really helps us understand
the sort of evolution of processes in
the universe from the earliest times to
the present and how the current universe
that we live in and see around us
locally came to be from the Big Bang
itself this is a Hubble picture well
known Hubble picture it's on the wall
over here to the left in case you want
to look at it more carefully later a
beautiful picture that was done by
pointing Hubble at one point of the sky
and exposing the the detectors on Hubble
for about a week and it was a piece of
the sky that where there was nothing
particularly bright or interesting going
on and what it revealed almost as if you
know when you look at a little drop of
water under a microscope is a teeming
life of galaxies all of which at all
distances out to the most distant
galaxies that can be detected by by
present means Chandra did the same thing
Chander's field of view is actually a
lot bigger so it's picture is much much
bigger but in this exact same piece of
sky Chandra also looked for roughly a
week and to try to find out what was
there and I can these results are only
just now coming out this is a this is
was given to me by our colleagues at
Penn State here's a picture of just that
piece of the sky the Chandra image and
now you can see only certain ones of
these
objects are hot enough or energetic
enough to glow brightly in x-rays each
one of these is something different some
of them are already been identified as
supermassive black holes of the kind
I've just been talking about quasars
that's lurk in the hearts of massive
galaxies others appear to be relatively
normal galaxies that we wouldn't have
thought have some kind of energetic
phenomena at the center but but when you
look with x-rays you find that they are
and this is something which is just now
people are starting to to be able to do
to push to the largest distances the
highest energies and figure out what in
these this variety of objects that you
see in a visible picture can tell us
about the energetic processes in the
universe that we see in x-rays
well Chandra is itself whoops
went too far what does it keep doing
that Chandra is itself an astronomical
object this is a picture taken by an
amateur astronomer in in Alabama shortly
after the Chandra launched and you can
see this little streak here is Chandra
moving across the sky during the time it
took for him to expose this picture I
don't remember how long that was and
it's in a very high orbit as I indicated
which will last at least 50 years if
anybody's done the calculation of
perturbations on the orbit the design
life of Chandra is five years but we
have no reason to believe it shouldn't
last at least 10 and NASA has obligingly
put in enough funding for us to operate
it for 10 years at least we have every
reason to believe it's going to be
continue to be as functioning as well
because the engineers here and elsewhere
did such a good job building it and and
returning as many exciting results as
we've just had a chance to glimpse so
far in fact I have a feeling right now
myself of having kind of walked into a
banquet with a huge smorgasbord table
and I've just gotten through the first
you know few appetizers and although I'm
all I might feel like I'm already full I
just can't wait to get on to the main
course the results from this mission are
really I think going to change a lot of
what we know and think we know about the
universe
there will be more surprises to come the
one surprise that I used to tell people
before a launch that their thing one
thing that would surprise me most would
be if Chandra didn't give us any
surprises and I think already from where
we can see I'm not going to be
disappointed thank you very much I'm
happy to take some questions
Tom could you flip switch things exposed
your times what are the exposure times
for these images they range for the
probably the shortest would be about 20
minutes and the longest ones so far you
know our you know week to ten days for
the those we can't do too many of
obviously more typically they may go for
you know hours would be sort of probably
the the median observation the these
these x-rays arrive very slowly the
typical for for a lot of sources that
were detecting the rate of the actual
photon arrival is fractions of photons
per second so you know tens photon every
10 seconds would be you know a pretty
good deal for in our business yes
it's thought that usually they come in
both directions and that one the study
of this of the counter jet if there is
one has been kind of interesting it
looks like there is something going in
the other direction some of that could
well be a as a selection based on
so-called doppler boosting I mean if
you're seeing the you know you get
enhanced the relativistic effect is such
as you get enhanced emission along the
direction and a lot of the Jets that are
seen in this business and many of which
were all of which were first detected in
the in the radio part of the spectrum
where you're looking at the synchrotron
radiation of these electrons and you're
probably seeing just the ones that are
boosted because they they're they're
beamed in a forward direction it's
probably a beaming effect for the most
part but but if there may be somewhere
where for some reason it really is
lopsided are these related to cosmic
rays they they they may be I mean it's
thought right now that most of the
cosmic rays that that we see are
probably come from things like supernova
explosions although now people are
talking about very energetic cosmic rays
may come from gamma-ray bursts or
something like that the weather active
galaxies generate a significant number
of cosmic rays I you know I'm not sure
they're probably some hole that they do
but I don't know that there's any firm
evidence of that fact yet Tony
can we detect emissions from really
heavy elements we we actually first of
all it turns out that mainly what we're
seeing are the most cosmically abundant
elements as I say the signals are fairly
weak and so we see things up to up to
iron maybe some indication of nickel
heavier elements are produced presumably
in the explosion of themselves their
products of the they're synthesized
during the during the supernova
explosions and they may be there but we
they probably are there and such small
numbers that we wouldn't have expected
to see them mean yet and then you also
have to find ones that have
characteristic lines right in our part
of the spectrum so my guess is that
we're not going to be able to say too
much about the heaviest elements there
is a mission going up soon a European
mission called integral which actually
should have the ability to detect higher
energy gamma-ray lines from heavier
elements maybe closer in on our galaxy
at least but then would see some of the
heavier elements I didn't mention that
but the question is what about the state
of ionization we are seeing these
elements say nitrogen through iron in
very high states of ionization other
than iron most of what we're seeing are
in the either hydrogen like or helium
like state in other words it's oxygen
with all but one or all but two
electrons stripped off iron we see in a
variety of states but typically we have
at least ten electrons have already been
stripped off at these temperatures
that's the equilibrium value for those
ions that's correct and in the in the
astronomers notation which in which
oxygen eight means oxygen plus seven
four to a physicists you indicated at
least one example at the end and others
earlier where Chandra had followed
observations that Hubble had taken
indivisible was a good synergy between
them have we started to see examples in
the other
no we have I mean people have proposed
to do Hubble observations to to make
sense of their Chandra observations and
in fact right now in an extraordinarily
cooperative move between the two
observatories they're actually when you
proposal to send in one proposal to do
simultaneous or contemporaneous Chandra
and Hubble observations so there is a
desire to to make the most of these
observatories in those cases where
that's a useful thing to do
yeah so the question the question is
could could the this this gasps in in in
clusters be something about the missing
what its relation to the missing mass in
the universe the it isn't a plasma state
it's it's a hot plasma at typically you
know 30 to 100 million degrees and it's
and it's enriched with with with heavy
elements not as much as in the Sun about
1/3 as much as what we see in the solar
system or in the in the galaxies but it
is not anywhere near enough to provide
the so-called missing mass in the
universe in fact it is very useful
because since these are large gret the
largest gravitationally bound objects in
the universe they probably have an
appropriate they probably have a mix of
abnormal matter very ons dark and dark
matter that's that's similar to the
average in the universe as a whole
and all the models seem to indicate and
theories seem to indicate that that's
the case and so what we see is that all
of the normal matter including the x-ray
gas which is typically three times what
you see in the stars three or more times
what you see in the stars so almost all
the normal matter is in x-ray plasma and
and then there's the dark matter because
the gravity that you in that you deduce
from the motions of this in fact from
the just to confine the hot gas itself
requires another almost 10 times more
material and so that's where this
statement comes that there still has to
be dark matter
so in fact studying that x-ray gas is
probably the best way to really deduce
how much dark matter there has to be
okay thank you best use the space
graduate students or ship and the thanks
to not only to you but to all of your
colleagues who've made this possible to
extraordinary
you